[Music]
to
being reunited no your eyes and ears
aren't deceiving you that's kristin
cavallari in the season 2 trailer for
the hills new beginnings
and it looks like this next chapter is
all about moving forward
we see audrina patridge reveal that she
shared a kiss with newly single brodie
jenner
brody and i we did kiss it's hard being
a single mom
dating i don't want to end up with the
wrong guy and brody
he dives into the reasons behind his
highly publicized split
from caitlyn carter there's been so much
speculation about like why we broke up
i've heard a lot of people that i love
and that's not the brody i want to be
the trailer also teases a rift between
heidi and spencer pratt
over their family plans i thought we
were getting more serious about trying
to get pregnant is that
dangerous for a baby for you to be so
stressed out every day
and when eti spoke with the couple last
year they teased
a lot of drama when it comes to their
co-stars and their relationships
i think there's a lot of people on the
rebound too from former relationships
that might be looking for new
relationships i think there's a lot of
drama going on in people's
marriages and lives too that will be
interesting to play out so
there's a lot of stuff going on and it
looks like there might be some drama
between
spencer and jason waller he's worked so
hard for his recovery
i don't know if he's sober not only is
jason working through his past
substance abuse issues he's also
focusing on his marriage to wife ashley
and the arrival of their second child
i'm having all these
fears i'm having all these triggers we
even see good old bachelor justin bobby
contemplate the possibility of settling
down
i enjoy being your father i'm starting
to see kids and the wife and i'm like
i can handle that and perhaps the most
scene stealing moment
the return of kristin cavallari
[Music]
to being reunited yeah i'm gonna make an
appearance on the house
are you so excited i am excited i'm
actually very excited
yeah i think it's gonna be fun to go
back and see the old gang and
you know yeah i'm really i'm looking
forward to it kristin
opened up to e.t about her return to the
mtv reality show back in
march 2020 but when e.t caught up with
kristen
again in september she said fans
shouldn't expect to see her become
a hills regular heidi and adriana came
on very cavalry so the trade-off was
episode for episodes so yes i do have to
do an episode but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna be a real cream person on
the show
maybe i'll go and stir some things up
you know and then leave
one episode stir the pot and i'm out but
no recurring cast members no
no you know my host eyes are over
[Music]